im letzten halben Jahr konnte man sich
auf eins verlassen jede Woche kamen neue
schlagzeahlen zu neuen umfragerekorden
der AFD gleichzeitig haben die
ampelparteien und die Union ihre
Rhetorik zum migrationsthema verschärft
da kann man schon fast den Eindruck
bekommen die AFD hat ihr Versprechen
wirklich gehalten wir werden sie jagen
seit die Partei 2017 in den Bundestag
eingezogen ist macht sie so richtig
Druck auf die wie die AFD sagen würde
altpartei der alte Bundestag wurde
abgewählt das Volk hat entschieden nun
beginnt eine neue Epoche meine Damen und
Herren und das schlägt sich längst in
der Realität nieder neben den
rekordumfragewerten gab es 2023 auch
Wahlerfolge in Hessen und Bayern den
ersten AFD Landrat in Thüringen und den
ersten AFD Oberbürgermeister in Sachsen
und der Rest der Parteienlandschaft ja
der weiß irgendwie auch nicht so richtig
die FDP wir geflüchteten kein Geld mehr
auszahlen sondern Sachleistungen
verteilen SPD-Kanzler Olaf Scholz
fordert Abschiebungen im großen Stil
cduchef Friedrich Merz spricht von
kleinen Paschas und meint damit
männliche Jugendliche mit muslimischem
Background und sogar die Grünen finden
Abschiebung jetzt auf einmal okay
zumindest Teile der Partei und in diese
Gemengelage kracht dann auch noch eine
Veröffentlichung vom recherchenetzwerk
Korrektiv Überschrift Geheimplan gegen
Deutschland darin legt das
recherchenetzwerk offen wie
rechtsextreme afdptiker und mindestens
zwei Mitglieder der CDU bei einem
geheimen Treffen die Vertreibung von
Millionen Menschen aus Deutschland
geplant haben der Plan der rechten sie
wollen Menschen mit Migrationsgeschichte
im großen Stil deportieren egal ob Sie
einen deutschen Pass besitzen oder nicht
der Aufschrei in Politik und
Gesellschaft ist riesig hundertausende
Menschen gehen im ganzen Land auf die
Straßen sie protestieren gegen die AFD
und gegen Rechtsextremismus aber was
soll das alles ist das was wir hier
gerade beschrieben haben der sogenannte
Rechtsruck das alles schauen wir uns in
der neuen Folge vom ZDF heute
backgroundcheck an ich bin Victoria
Reichelt schön dass ihr dabei seid und
damit ihr auch in Zukunft nichts
verpasst abonniert hier den Kanal und
drückt die
Glocke so und jetzt schauen wir uns als
erstes mal die AFD an denn die Partei
ist ja schon ein Phänomen ich meine die
haben in den letzten Jahren drei ihrer
Vorsitzenden quasi rausgeekelt immer
wieder gibt es skandalauftritte in
Talkshows die Medien berichten von
spendengelderfähen und gleichzeitig
nähert sich die AFD dem
Rechtsextremismus immer weiter an und
trotzdem oder gerade deshalb ist die
Partei seit Monaten auf einem enormen
Höhenflug was ist da los ist sind aus
der Forschungsliteratur wissen wir das
seit Jahrzehnten im Prinzip erstmal
immer zwei Gründe die dazu führen dass
re auusenparteien stark werden die
müssen im Prinzip zusammenkommen um so
eine Welle zu verursachen wir haben uns
für dieses Thema Hilfe ins Haus geholt
und zwar von Politikwissenschaftler
Floris bisskam gemeinsam haben wir uns
die Entwicklung der AFD angeschaut denn
man könnte ja auch sagen die AFD ist
eine reine Erfolgsgeschichte die nur
eine Richtung kennt und zwar nach oben
2013 gegründet 2017 in den Bundestag
eingezogen und Mitte 2023 sind die
umfragewerwerte höher als die der
Kanzlerpartei SPD aber so einfach ist es
natürlich nicht die Wahrheit ist die die
Geschichte der AFD ist bisher ein Auf
und Ab zwischenzeitlich wurde sie fast
schon für Tod erklärt AFD in Zeiten von
Corona vom Überflieger zum extremrechten
loser Stichwort extremrechter loser die
AFD gilt heute bundesweit als
rechtsextremer Verdachtsfall in drei
Bundesländern in Thüringen SachsenAnhalt
und Sachsen hat der Verfassungsschutz
die Partei sogar als gesichert
rechtsextrem eingestuft nur die
Beschreibung loser trifft mittlerweile
nicht mehr so richtig zu auf die
Beliebtheit der AFD hatte das ganze
nämlich keinen negativen Einfluss im
Gegenteil denn nachdem sich die
Nachrichten vom extremrechten
coronaluser im Land verbreiteten erholte
sich die Partei von ihrem Umfragetief
sie räumte bei den Landtagswahlen in
Bayern und Hessen ab sie stellt ihren
ersten Landrat im thüringischen
Sonneberg und den ersten
Oberbürgermeister in PNA im Osten von
Sachsen Ende 2023 stand sie in der
Sonntagsfrage bei über 20%. das ist
doppelt so viel wie in der coronazeit ah
ja und apropos Osten wären in
Ostdeutschland nächsten Sonntag
Landtagswahlen würde das ganze wohl so
aussehen die Frage die sich hier
natürlich stellt wieso ist die AFD
aktuell so beliebt und wie gehen die
anderen Parteien mit dem Erfolg um
lassen Sie sich wirklich jagen wir
werden sie jagen wir müssen endlich im
großen Stil abschieben das hat Olaf
Scholz in einem spiegelinterview Mitte
Oktober gesagt na ja und der Aufschrei
war groß die Linken Abgeordnete Nicole
Golke schreibt damals auf Ex dem
früheren Twitter offenbar geht in diesen
Tagen im großen Stil nur der Rechtsruck
und Johannes Wagner twittert ich finde
das eines sozialdemokratischen Kanzlers
unwürdig Wagner sitzt übrigens für die
Grünen im Bundestag also als Teil der
Ampelkoalition aber ist das Statement
von Scholz wirklich so ein neuer
Aufreger in ihrem Koalitionsvertrag
haben SPD Grüne und FDP doch auch schon
2021 das hier geschrieben nicht jeder
Mensch der zu uns kommt kann bleiben wir
starten eine rückführungsoffensive um
ausreisen konsequenter umzusetzen klingt
also da schon nach im großen Stil
abschieben und als die ampelparteien das
geschrieben haben stand die AFD bei 11%.
was das angeht könnten wir also sagen
zumindest dieser Satz von Scholz muss
mit den aktuellen Umfragewerten erstmal
nichts zu tun haben trotzdem ist das
Thema Migration damit ja nicht vom Tisch
in der Art wie über diese Probleme
gesprochen wird und wie dann damit
umgegangen wird kann man das glaube ich
schon so sagen dass da
in Reaktion auf die Erfolge der AFD die
anderen Parteien Punkte von der AFD
übernehmen dafür gibt es einige
Beispiele das vielleicht
offensichtlichste ist das sogenannte
rückführungsverbesserungsgesetz der
Ampel dadurch soll schneller und
einfacher abgeschoben werden können
erstmal klingt das nach dem was schon im
isvertrag stand rückführungsoffensive
eben aber die Ampel will mit ihrem
Gesetzesentwurf noch weitergehen es
sollen auch neue Gründe für Abschiebung
eingeführt und einige Rechte von
geflüchteten eingeschränkt werden wer
z.B Mitglied einer kriminellen
Vereinigung ist soll in Zukunft ohne
Gerichtsurteil abgeschoben werden können
und bei Abschiebung in
Gemeinschaftsunterkünften sollen die
Behörden auch die Zimmer der Bewohner
betreten dürfen die eigentlich gar nicht
abgeschoben werden sollen viele
kritisieren das als Eingriff in die
Privatsphäre der geflüchteten das
rückführungsverbesserungsgesetz der
Ampel ist aber längst nicht die einzige
Entwicklung in Richtung streng engere
Asyl und Migrationspolitik diese beiden
fdpminister haben z.B gefordert
geflüchteten kein Geld mehr für ihren
Lebensunterhalt zu zahlen sondern nur
noch Sachleistung das würde bedeuten die
Kommunen müssen Essen Kleidung
Hygieneartikel und so weiter für die
geflüchteten organisieren die rechtliche
Grundlage dafür ist auch schon lange da
aber die Kommunen haben wegen des hohen
Aufwandes Bedenken angemeldet diesen
Vorschlag hat aber auch die CDU
unterstützt und die geht noch weiter der
Ministerpräsident von NRW Hendrik wüst
hat das sogenannte Ruanda Modell nach
britischem Vorbild vorgeschlagen das
bedeutet Deutschland könnte geflüchtete
in ein Flugzeug nach Ruanda setzen egal
aus welchem Land die Menschen nach
Deutschland gekommen sind die
geflüchteten müssen ihr Asylverfahren
dann in Ruanda durchlaufen nach dem dort
geltenden Asylrecht das Land liegt
übrigens in der Mitte des afrikanischen
Kontinents das nur als zeitnote SPD
Innenministerin nen fesa lässt ihr
Ministerium jetzt prüfen ob das machbar
ist mit Ruanda oder anderen Staaten
außerhalb der EU vor ein paar Jahren
wäre sowas für die SPD wohl eher ein no
Goo gewesen in Großbritannien ist das
Ruanda Modell schon länger Thema da
wurde es allerdings vom ob obsten
Gerichtshof gekippt die Begründung es
sei nicht sicher ob beim Asylverfahren
in Ruanda die Menschenrechte eingehalten
werden die britische Regierung will
trotzdem daran festhalten und wagt einen
neuen Anlauf aber zurück nach
Deutschland denn Henrik wüst ist nicht
der einzige aus der CDU der sich für das
Ruanda Modell stark macht auch Jens span
unterstützt die Idee und er hat auch
noch gesagt gegebenenfalls müsse man mit
physischer Gewalt irreguläre
Migrationsbewegungen aufhalten gerade in
der Union scheint man zu glauben dass
der Erfolg darin liegt wenn man sich
zumindest auf diesem themenfä in diese
Richtung bewegt beim Thema Migration
kann man also sagen vor allem die Union
ist mindestens von der AFD verunsichert
das sieht man auch daran dass der
CDU-Vorsitzende Friedrich März 2018 noch
gesagt hat wer traue sich zu die AFD zu
halbieren davon hat er sich mittlerweile
verabschiedet stattdessen hat er dann
sogar gesagt die CDU sei eine
Alternative für Deutschland mit Substanz
bei SPD und Grünen ist meine Vermutung
eher dass die das Thema jetzt bedienen
gar nicht weil sie denken dass sie damit
Erfolge haben sondern sie eher das Thema
jetzt so einmal abräumen wollen dass sie
irgendwie dafür sorgen wollen dass dann
wenige Menschen kommen und das Thema
nicht mehr so groß ist übrigens
Expertinnen und Experten sagen dass das
rückführungsverbesserungsgesetz der
Ampel gerade mal für 600 Abschiebung
mehr im Jahr sorgen könnte gerade für
die Grünen ist das Thema Migration ein
Dilemma das sehen wir schon wenn wir uns
nur eine einzige grüne angucken 2020 hat
sich Ricarda lang noch mit dem Spruch
wir haben Platz vs Kanzleramt gestellt
und sich für die Aufnahme von
geflüchteten eingesetzt heute fordert
sie als grünen kchefin mehr Abschiebung
zu ermöglichen wir sehen die Grünen
haben sich einigen Überzeugungen
verabschiedet aber aus der Partei gab es
auch viel Kritik an der Parteispitze der
wurde z.B vorgeworfen Begriffe von
rechts zu übernehmen was an der Stelle
klar wird die AFD wirkt offenbar auf
alle Parteien das hat natürlich viel mit
ihren hohen Umfragewerten zu tun und das
bringt uns zurück zu unseren zwei großen
fragen warum ist die AFD so erfolgreich
und ist das jetzt alles schon ein
Rechtsruck wir haben ja schon am Anfang
des Videos angedeutet dass beim Erfolg
der AFD vor allem zwei entscheidende
Faktoren eine Rolle spielen das ist zum
einen die unzufrieden halt mit dem was
der politische Mainstream anzubieten hat
oder anders gesagt die Leute sind vor
allem mit der Arbeit der Regierung
unzufrieden das zeigen wirklich
miserable Umfragewerte kein Kanzler war
jemals so unbeliebt wie Olaf Scholz denn
die Ampel ist in den letzten Monaten vor
allem mit einem aufgefallen mit Streit
Migrationspolitik die
Kindergrundsicherung das
wachstumschancengesetz das Elterngeld
die energiepreisbremsen das
heizungsgesetz der Bundeshaushalt dass
die ampelparteien sich streiten scheint
ein echter Dauerzustand zu sein das ist
natürlich Futter für die Opposition die
Unionsparteien können immer wieder
Schwachstellen der Koalition offenlegen
als Opposition ist das ihr Job aber auch
hier gibt es ein Dilemma denn womöglich
profitieren nicht nur die CDU und CSU
davon also das war dann ja innerhalb der
Koalition ein extremer Hickhack wo die
CDU dann auch ordentlich mitgeschossen
hat und dass das dann zu Unzufriedenheit
führt ist relativ leicht nachvollziehbar
und wenn man so möchte ist die
Unzufriedenheit der Menschen im Land der
Diesel im Motor der der AFD das zweite
was kommen muss ist die Politisierung
von Migration wobei die
rechtsaußenparteinen dann besonders
stark profitieren wenn sie die Position
gegen Migration sehr stark vertreten
können und dann die entsprechenden
Gefühle resentim abgreifen können in
Situationen wo allgemein viel darüber
gesprochen wird wenn die Unzufriedenheit
im Land also der Diesel der AFD ist dann
ist das Thema Migration sowas wie ein
riesiger Tanklaster und den fährt die
AFD schon seit Jahren ziemlich Erfolg
ich wenn wir uns die Geschichte der AFD
in Umfrage Hochs und Tiefs anschauen
dann sehen wir ziemlich deutlich dass
die immer gerade dann besonders stark
waren wenn das Thema Flucht und
Migration auch sehr groß war als die AFD
2017 das erste Mal in den Bundestag
einzieht ist die Asylpolitik in der
öffentlichen Debatte ziemlich präsent
gut ein Drittel des tvdells zwischen
Angela Merkel und dem spdkandidaten
Martin Schulz dreht sich um dieses Thema
und von den afdwählern haben nach der
Wahl 100% angegeben dass sie mit der
Asylpolitik von Merkel undzu zufrieden
waren während die AFD ein Jahr später
diesen Höchstwert erreicht streiten sich
die Kanzlerin und ihr Innenminister
Horst Seehofer gerade über Asylpolitik
Seehofer wollte damals eine Obergrenze
für geflüchteten Zahlen durchsetzen
viele haben ihm vorgeworfen Forderung
und Rhetorik der AFD zu übernehmen nach
einer für CSU Verhältnisse
katastrophalen Landtagswahl in Bayern
grenzt sich die Union klar von der AFD
ab das migrationsthema war im Herbst
2018 auch vom Tisch und die Werte der
AFD sanken wieder und jetzt sehen wir so
eine ähnliche Entwicklung diesen Sommer
insbesondere ist Migration wieder ein
sehr großes Thema geworden und die AFD
ähm ist wieder sehr stark und die Frage
ist inwiefern dieses Thema dann ins Jahr
2024 und dann zur Bundestagswahl die
vermutlich ja 2025 sein wird m
weiterträgt um das an der Stelle mal
kurz zusammenzufassen die AFD verbucht
Rekordwert und räumt bei Landtagswahlen
ab während sie gleichzeitig immer
extremer wird und der Rest der
Parteienlandschaft wirkt zunehmend
nervöser März spricht von kleinen
Paschas die Ampel treibt eine
asylrechtsverschärfung voran bei den
Grünen treten Mitglieder aus weil sie
unzufrieden sind mit der strengeren
Asylpolitik aber ist das jetzt dieser
Rechtsruck von dem alle reden wir haben
im politischen System auf jeden Fall
einen deutlich erkennbaren Rechtsruck
also die AFD hat sich in den letzten 10
Jahren quasi kontinuierlich
radikalisiert und ist mittlerweile eine
recht eindeutig in rechtsextrem Spektrum
zuur verordnende Partei und während die
AFD fast schon eine etablierte Partei in
Deutschland geworden ist räumt die CDU
mit ihren Liberalen Positionen aus der
merkelzeit auf wenn wir uns aufs
Parteiensystem konzentrieren ist die
Antwort auf unsere Frage also ja da
sehen wir ein Rechtsruck aber das ist
nur ein Bereich von vielen und insgesamt
GT eher es kommt drauf an wenn wir uns
angucken was tatsächlich an Gesetzen in
den letzten 10 vielleicht auch 20 Jahren
beschlossen wurde ist es nämlich schon
wieder anders Floris biskamp hat uns
gesagt bei Asyl und Migration ging es im
Grunde immer nur um Verschärfung bei
anderen Themen ist das nicht so da wurde
es an vielen Stellen liberaler das beste
Beispiel dafür ist die Ehe für alle und
auch in der Gesellschaft beobachten wir
eigentlich keinen eindeutigen Rechtsruck
die meisten langzeitstudien zeigen dass
die Bevölkerung sich eher von von
autoritären und menschenfeindlichen
Positionen wegbewegt stattdessen
Selbstbestimmung und Akzeptanz wichtiger
werden in diesen Studien sieht man aber
auch es gibt Teile der Bevölkerung die
sehr feste rechtsextreme Überzeugungen
haben also die Einstellungen die
rechtsextrem sind gehen eigentlich
zurück aber die werden jetzt politisch
stärker mobilisiert erstens würde ich
sagen es gibt keinen
gesamtgesellschaftlichen Rechtsruck der
der Grund dafür wäre dass die AFD jetzt
so aufgestiegen ist was es aber gibt ist
so die Formierung eines
rechtsaußenprojekt es rund um die AFD
herum und dass auch wenn es mal
irgendwie an noch mehr Macht und
Einfluss kommt auch Demokratie gefähdend
wirken kann das sollte man auf keinen
Fall runterspielen eine Gefahr für die
Demokratie besteht also die AFD wird ja
auch nicht ohne Grund vom
Verfassungsschutz beobachtet und gilt in
Teilen als gesichert rechtsextrem gerade
mit Blick auf die Wahlen in
Ostdeutschland ist das relevant die
extremsten Landesverbände der AFD sind
die in Sachsen-Anhalt Thüringen Sachsen
und Brandenburg und wie wir am Anfang
gesehen haben aktuell ist die AFD dort
in UMF Fragen jeweils stärkste Partei
was aber dazu kommt der umfragenhype
bringt der AFD Aufmerksamkeit die
vielleicht zu noch höheren Werten führt
aber einfach nur nicht drüber reden
reicht am Ende nicht die anderen
Parteien tun sich damit teilweise echt
schwer bleibt die Frage was können sie
denn machen gute Politik wäre die ganz
kurze Antwort aber allgemein sollten die
anderen Parteien es schaffen politische
Projekte vorzustellen wo Menschen
glauben erstens das realistisch
umsetzbar und zweit das bringt mir was
und dann bin ich Teil von was sinnvoll
wenn ich das unterstütze und irgendwie
kommt für mich auch da am Ende ein
ordentliches Leben bei raus und das
scheint gerade nur sehr sporadisch zu
funktionieren jetzt will ich von euch
wissen welche anderen Thesen sollen wir
mal genauer angucken welche
verschwörungserzählung könnten wir für
euch durchleuchten schreibt uns das mal
in die Kommentare hier findet ihr unsere
bisherigen Folgen und hier könnt ihr den
Kanal abonnieren um keinen background
Check zu
verpassen